la première réaction qu'ils ont eu donc
ma famille au complet c'est clair mais
c'est quoi ce prénom de merde attendre
de tes origines s'étaient passées bien
petit déj
[Musique]
j'ai choisi un prénom français parce que
souvent quand on se sent français dans
ma roue vie d'avoir un prénom français
c'est déjà arrivé par le passé sans
voulant me comparer à ses illustres
personnages de la littérature française
par exemple je pense à romain gary qui
s'appelait romain roman et qui a appris
le prénom romain quand il est devenu
français ou encore marie curie qui
s'appelait maria voilà c'est aussi
simple que ça clair en fait c'était
l'aboutissement de ma quête d'identité
à ce moment là je ressens mais il ya une
joie indescriptible en fait je j'avais
l'impression enfin d'être réparé et
d'être enfin ce que j'ai toujours rêvé
d'être en fait une française une femme
française est une femme libre
enfin et donc j'arrive tout fier avec ma
carte d'identité française que je
grandis à mes parents sur dix est gelée
eu regard des jeux même changer de
prénom est la première réaction qu'ils
ont eu donc ma famille au complet
c'est clair mais c'est quoi ce prénom de
merde attendre de tes origines s'étaient
passées bien cheadle et il y avait en
plus la réaction de mes amis dont j'ai
une française que j'avais invité à venir
trinquer avec moi qui m'ont dit quoi tu
as chanté la marseillaise mais ces
violences et raciste comment on peut
faire ça des étrangers
[Musique]
leur initiation à la culture française
et à la langue française se passait
plutôt bien jusqu'à ce qu'ils soient
pris en charge par des associations
d'aidé aux migrants qui ont commencé à
leur dire qu'en fait ils avaient été mal
accueillie que son leur demander de
faire des efforts supplémentaires eh
bien c'est qu'ils avaient affaire à des
français racistes et puis notre notre
cité où on habitait a commencé à se
vider des dernières références
culturelles françaises deux dernières
familles d'origine française qui partait
qui étaient remplacés par d'autres
immigrés et en fait quand il ya une
forte population issue de la même
origine et bien les personnes n'ont plus
besoin de parler français en fait
puisqu'elle se comprennent dans leur
langue à ce qu'on prenne mieux dans leur
langue d'origine donc et ajoutez à cela
l'arrivée de la parabole fin des années
80 début des années 90 mes parents
étaient broncher 24 heures sur 24 sur la
télévision turque avec des programmes
turc
la france n'était plus là il y avait
plus en fait aucun aucune référence à la
culture française
[Musique]
j'avais tout
ou un statut complètement différent
j'étais plus une enfant j'étais une
fille j'étais devenue une fille par
rapport à mes frères j'ai deux frères
toutes les corvées l'été elle était à ma
charge
je devais nettoyer la maison faire
briller la maison faire les courses
emmenés par fois mes parents à la
pharmacie ou chez le médecin pour faire
la traduction en fait cette culture
anatolienne qu'ils avaient laissés dans
leur pays
elle est revenue mais violemment mon
père par exemple me disait tout le temps
tu es toi tu es une fille
[Musique]
et qu'il y avait une fête
où un goûter à l'école vont nous
demander d'apporter des plats de notre
pays d'origine ou des vêtements de notre
pays d'origine c'est très bien une fois
ça va mais quand c'est répétitif on dit
mais qu'est ce qui se passe en fait on
n'est pas français on est différent mes
parents voulaient que je fasse une fois
le bon choix celui de la turquie et à
l'école d'art public les enseignants
entre autres mes camarades de classe
même renvoyé constamment à mon identité
j'appelle ça l'assignation à résidence
identitaire perpétuel et ça c'était dur
parce qu'à un moment vous savez plus en
fait vous savez plus que vous êtes
[Musique]
ce qui m'a sauvé aussi c'est
bon c'était mon espace de liberté
j'écoutais véronique sanson balavoine et
je me disais voilà je regardais par la
fenêtre tous les soirs je disais je vais
partir je vais partir d'ici c'est pas
pour moi et la télévision quand mes
parents n'étaient pas l'âge je l'allumé
et c'était ma seule fenêtre sur la
culture française mois la télévision
elle m'a appris à parler français
elle m'a appris à m'habiller m'a appris
à manger elle m'a appris à découvrir la
culture française vraiment
[Musique]
il ne me parle plus mes parents ma
famille plus personne ne parle je suis
devenu une paria
parce que j'ai en plus épousé un
français d'origine et ce qui ne va pas
du tout pour eux
[Musique]
il ya un événement très très très fort
je me souviens c'est les attentats du 13
novembre 2015
je travaillais dans une rédaction et
tout le monde avait besoin de parler
et en fait j'ai voulu m'exprimer j'ai
dit que j'avais accroché le drapeau
français à ma fenêtre que j'avais eu ce
besoin là de montrer que j'étais fière
d'être française et le mot fierté a fait
tilt chez un de mes collègues qui m'a
dit arrête arrête avec ce mot là ces
fachos et je me suis dit waouh
même dans ces moments terribles même là
c'est ce collègue m'avait demandé de la
boucle est quoi et si je l'avais dit que
j'étais fier d'être sûr qu'il aurait
trouvé ça formidable
c'est ça qui fait qu'il est incroyable
en fait encore une fois c'est ces
personnes là qui vous demande de faire
un choix ils ont fait le choix pour vous
c'est ça être mal accueillie
[Musique]
vous pouvez venir de n'importe où du
monde des quatre coins du monde et pour
peu que vous et couzier les valeurs de
la république française qui sont la
liberté l'égalité et la fraternité
eh bien vous êtes français c'est aussi
simple que ça si je me sentais sûr
j'irai vivre en turquie
je parle de mon cas personnel mais moi
je me sens française donc il est saoul
logique que votre devis mes choix soit
soit calquée sur mon le pays dans lequel
je vis en plus le pays que j'aime